your directorial debut here of all of
your past writing and producing
experience which particular production
did you think set you up for the most
success as a Helmer on your first film
you know I don't think it was one
particular project but I will say it's
probably my 17 years as a TV writer
producer having to be on set and you
know deal with the pre-production
production post-production that most set
me up for this and in addition to that I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't the
mentorship and allyship of my fellow
director friends like John Chu who
directed crazy Rich Asians I had to put
myself through at home director school
for this movie during the pandemic and
he would just get on the zooms with me
and you know coach me through things
what is the best piece of advice you got
from him or somebody else about what it
takes to direct a feature film first of
all having complete confidence in your
vision and in your um in your sense of
story but the uh the most important
practical piece of advice was to be in
the moment that as a writer you know you
you exist in like um the past and like
what the movie was what you're doing now
what you're going to be doing tomorrow
as the Director you want to just be in
the moment be with your actors you know
are we laughing and crying the way we
need to in this scene so that our
audience can feel it and that was
tremendously helpful so now for another
uh future first time feature director
out there what advice would you get give
them how would you pay it forward I paid
for it and that you know I'm just gonna
off John Chu which is with the
passage to success which is that to have
faith in your vision and the moment you
start trying to make everybody happy or
you try to operate from a place of fear
you are just you're not doing a service
to yourself just go with it you know in
success or failure at least you are
telling your story well I have so many
follow-up questions to that first
because I love hearing about Studios and
producers who support their director's
voice and I know you have that here with
with Lionsgate and uh great point what
is something about the studio director
relationship that they struck with you
that you really appreciated and hope
that more directors working with Studios
on comedies like this can have in the
future uh there are not a lot of female
directors in the future in the future
world and definitely not a lot of female
directors of color so when Point gray
suggested that perhaps you know I could
put myself in that role uh first of all
was that allyship that made me believe
that it was even possible but when I met
with Lionsgate they could not have been
more supportive and bigger allies to
myself personally and to our project we
have a crazy first of its kind already
nasty comedy with four Asian American
faces at its Center and at some point we
thought surely surely a grown-up was
gonna come in and say like you know
um listen Missy like we don't know what
you're trying to do but you gotta like
Reign it back and that never happened to
their credit they said we they
understood what we were going for and
encouraged us to lean even hard harder
in that direction I love that I reverse
Point gray
do you know what a spoonerism is yes I
do it I do it all the time all the time
I switch sentences like you know the
structure of sex do it deliberately for
fun and then I'll do it accidentally
because I've been doing it for fun I'm a
professional writer you think I would
know Mary pemeroff I love it I love it
I'll call myself that all day long um
speaking about you know believing in
your own voice and sticking to it how do
you apply that mentality to you know
things like test screenings and getting
notes and suggestions from others how do
you kind of draw the line between you
know knowing when to listen to someone
else versus knowing when to you know
trust your gut say thank you for the
suggestion but no I gotta go with what I
believe in I come from working in
television which is a very collaborative
medium and I think the best writers and
creators are
um are people who understand that to be
surrounded with a room full of smarter
people is exactly the position you want
to be in and being able to listen to all
those notes finding a way to have those
notes plus your project and not diminish
but ultimately you are the filter for
that you're the one you're the you're
that inflection point for your own movie
so being able to take in all of that
input see what helps you and what
doesn't and sometimes open you up to a
different perspective and see what's
funny and what's not what's
heartbreaking what's not can you give me
an example of both a time where someone
made a suggestion that opens you up to
something new but then also a time where
you had to listen to your own instincts
and know that regardless of suggestions
you were going that route absolutely um
I think there's one joke in the movie
about Splinter uh where
um uh the character of Audrey says you
know it's like when I masturbate I think
about Splinter ever seeing that going
like this is ridiculous I don't know
what we're even doing here
um I felt like you know it was too much
it was crazy but you know they uh uh
Josh Fagan at Point gray fought hard for
it and we and the great thing about test
audience is that you can test these
theories you can test the jokes you can
test the heartfelt moments and that joke
worked and you know once something works
you can't argue with it I'm literally
going straight from here to talk about
Ninja Turtles ah makes all the sense in
the world to me yeah so how about uh the
opposite now a time where like you felt
very strongly about something and you
were gonna stick to it no matter what
yeah well you know the story has like
this stealth
um through line of heart
um that there's a point in the story
that we're all feeling for the character
and even crying and this is right off of
you know laughing at some insanely
inappropriate moments
um I am working with comedy writers and
producers but I come from a drama
background and especially in a movie
like this where it can be so crazy you
want it rooted in something real
something authentic and so I think for
all the stories where
um the characters really resonated with
our heart and fighting and making sure
that
um it doesn't feel like we're taking
away from the comedy I think we are just
helping support uh the funny
storytelling that we're doing by making
sure these characters feel real that
we're crying for them the balance you
strike in that respect here is
exceptional so I imagine you go into
this shoot with a plan but as happens
with making anything film things don't
always go according to plan so can you
give me an example of a day on set when
things weren't going to plan and you had
to find a creative way to Pivot and
maybe you found some unexpected magic
you know that's a great question so my
favorite moments of the movie are things
that were not originally scripted for
that point we had originally some insane
big set piece where our characters were
crossing a river on a water buffalo and
um a fun fact uh you know not the
easiest thing to pull off uh water
buffalo in Canada maybe don't want to
get into the water maybe maybe their
fleas maybe it's not a good idea to put
your brilliant talented cast into a
river in the fall in Canada
so we scrapped that thank the thank
goodness and instead we had we always
had the K-pop element but at that point
we decided to make that element a bigger
set piece than it was and I am so
excited that we did that really is one
of the high points of the movie no
disrespect to water buffalo but we can't
stuff deserved all the time in the
spotlight it got I will say
congratulations on Joyride but I will
also say Roy jide I think everybody out
there should see it thank you so much
for your time today oh my gosh thank you